glass to me is pretty much crazy cool I
make a collection of very bespoke
and unique glass objects that each have
their own aesthetic from an early age in
high school in Bermuda I was lucky
enough to have a kiln I was able to look
at how organically you can create
something with limited resources you
know you've got mud and something to
ignite it with flames and you know
wallah you've got a sculpture that will
last forever I've looked at woodwork
metalwork digital processes and then
fundamentally having glass as a main
medium I came across glassblowing and
glass sculpting and I instantly had a
full-on just fascination with how
material could be manipulated and so
many different ways well blowing is what
the oldest techniques and in my own
practice I'm able to sustainably make
dozens of pieces from one digital mode
which helps for productivity and there's
no byproducts no waste a lot of my work
begins with sketches and drawings and
then evolving into more of a digital
platform and looking at computerized
edit from that point moving on to more
of a 3d basis and then sculpting and 3d
cutting and forming objects from these
sketches from the beginning of my
practice rationally I was very aware of
the limitations of glass making and how
accessible it is to certain places
around the world and looking at the
cultural imprint behind glass making it
is there I have a strong heart for being
an inspiration to younger people of any
background and any ethnicity is really
really significant for them to be aware
that this occupation that doesn't seem
viable to them because of color of the
skin or their personality you shouldn't
not do it because essentially is is
something that you have a passion for a
lot of the work I do is looking at this
is someone's reality this is what they
see over and over again how do you
breach beyond that reality when I'm
working with glass is a constant battle
between my mental state and my physical
state feels like a film a sense of
suspense and drama and knowing that if
you don't respect what you're doing it
could all go terribly wrong a constant
challenge of rate of sweat heat and fire
I think one of the roles traditional
craft plays within my own practice is
sustainability having a sense of
longevity within the work that I do is
really important to me because it's
touching on the culture and heritage
behind glass making and having the
ability to implement digital base
concepts and designs and really
utilizing a new contemporary style is a
real testament to traditional making
[Music]